hey everyone I'm rami malek and I'm
going undercover on the Internet
here we go okay it's actually me Cora
what was Romney Malik's first movie
night at the museum remember that right
I think that was it yes it was and what
a fun movie to work on with the late
great Robin Williams and I learned so
much from him here's a good Robin
Williams story we were doing Night at
the Museum 3 and we were shooting in the
British Museum of all places at night
and I see Robin just standing alone by
himself it got pretty close to him
walked up to him and he was just staring
off in the distance and said are you
okay he says back man
how often are we gonna get a chance to
stand right in front of the rosetta
stone and that was just a magnificent
moment that I shall never forget now I
get to share it with you so here's to
mr. Williams lovely Robin submit what is
wrong a mouse really snort in the
morphine scenes of mr. robot
well obviously morphine right how can I
not say that read it I wonder how many
times rami malek had to watch that live
aid show in order to synchronize slash
choreograph his performance to the
original a lot I'd like to say that I
picked it up pretty quickly but Freddie
and the band are so spontaneous that it
was quite time-consuming to figure out
every single move I watched it probably
thousands of times our cast collectively
contributed to thousands upon thousands
of YouTube hits rely bait it took quite
a long time
seriously it's actually me I had he had
Freddie Mercury teeth he wore while
filming
you mean Rhapsody and cast in gold true
I did I thought what would be the most
ostentatious Freddy thing I could do and
because I had to wear those teeth every
day I grew so close to them and
appreciated them so much that I thought
I would honor the film and Freddy by
giving myself a freddy mercury grille
Twitter at its rami malek how did you
feel about your character in the Pacific
did you like playing snafu feel any
depth I loved playing that character
that was one of the seminal roles I have
ever had and I learned so much from that
experience we did a military boot camp
that bonded this group of actors
together much like Band of Brothers
it's a project I hold near and dear to
my heart I think I just done the Night
at the Museum I came in for Tom Hanks
and says I'm a fan of your work and he
was shocked and just taken aback and I
looked at him I said likewise people
started to laugh which made it easier to
continue auditioning and it's a very
intimidating room and I realized that
the casting associate happened to look a
lot like Steven Spielberg and it was
that's fun inclined rami malek is the
new Bond villain question mark
exclamation I was working on Bohemian
Rhapsody for two years in London and I
got to play Freddie Mercury of course
which is a national treasure and now I
get to do this Bond film which is not
only a national treasure and well
Freddie's a world treasure too
but who doesn't appreciate Bond movies
didn't ever think I'd play James Bond
but thought I might have a chance of
playing the villain and here it is
submit again he has remarked that he
enjoys the auditioning process sees it
as a proving ground to test things out
and has created so many diverse
characters for
additions that he wishes he could
collect them as a package to show others
yeah I would take the time to prepare
for auditions as if I was actually going
to perform I would come with something
fully formed and hope that that
resonated sometimes it did many times it
didn't but that's the proving ground and
I appreciate it so yes true the
importance of preserving their Egyptian
roots his father would wait to sign up
in the middle of the night to talk to
his Arabic speaking extended family and
their home tune of some of Egypt that's
true would wake up and talk to all my
cousins in Egypt as a kid and really
appreciate that treasured memory more
Twitter
do you ever slip into character for fun
when you're not on set to give you a new
perspective not really because Carly and
I just have too much fun hanging out as
ourselves that gal is like a sister to
me now after all these years of shooting
this show we're coming to the close of
mr. robot it's her final season and it's
hard to think of Carly as Darlene now
because she's seriously family to me
it's like hanging out with your coolest
sister most of the time just curious now
that you've learned to play the piano
for Bohemian Rhapsody do you still play
the piano I do I wish I did more I find
it incredibly therapeutic it's something
I never thought I'd be able to do and
still a learning process for me but
getting the hang of it and I love it
next question did they stop making this
podcast blackout no they didn't we
didn't made a podcast with some
incredible artists and shout there check
it out I'm not plugging myself but it
came out so here it is
reply alright that was fun signing off
see you soon
you